You mentioned that it's too late to fight the cause, but time to fight the cancer.
No, let's make sure we understand. It's never too late to fight the cause.
It's never too late to deal with cause. So let's say my cause and my cancer is was a toxicity.
If something gets, remember, cancer is something gets inside the cell.
It could be anything, anything that gets intracellular inside the cell and damages the DNA.
It damages the DNA and causes the DNA to go into a rapid replication, replicating cells that are in rapid replication now with that same damage DNA.
Now, fighting, getting rid of the cause is important. You detox that. You get rid of that.
So it doesn't get in another cell and cause cancer again, you know, a totally different cancer.
So it's so important to deal with the cause plus cause is more than just what specifically damaged the DNA causes.
What, why did I have a suppressed immune system? Why, you know, why is my parasympathetic system down?
Well, you know, that's why people under a greater amount of stress have an increased incidence of cancer.
So there's lots of pieces to that cause too that you have to deal with that you are dealing with that we make you guys deal with when we're trying to treat the cancer.
So you are dealing with the cause. So don't, I didn't say it's too late to fight the cause. You are dealing with the cause.
But you also have to kill the cancer cells. So just because let's say I could, let's say I couldn't wave a magic wand.
Let's see the cause of my cancer was toxin and if I wave the magic wand and that coxins were all on my body just like that.
Well, the kids are still growing. So the damage the damage was done. It's not continually damaging and the damage was done.
So I still have to kill the cancer. So just because that's why I mean, otherwise we would just be toxic you guys and you wouldn't use a knife and you wouldn't stimulate your immune system.
And we would be talking about this until we wouldn't be talking about possibly chemotherapy.
We would have to fight the cancer because it would just go away. So it doesn't work that way.
Once the damage of the DNA is there, you still have to kill the cancer. So understand you have to deal with the cause.
And if you don't, it's to your demise. You are all our patients are, but we also have to kill the cancer. So your book you mentioned, lay a trail needs time to build up the therapeutic doses. Well, that's true.
Really everything does. You start taking mushrooms. It's going to take a few weeks to get really to therapeutic doses meeting that builds up in your body to really start killing the cancer.
Same thing with lay a trail, but I think I in the book, I said that because there was a study about that.
Um, would that be something that it's too late to do something I don't have time for? No, I would say no, I would say you still.
There, there's still time for that.